[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember I see you don't have to I don't
know why we didn't have our usual intro
or why there's a lesser quality camera
next to a high quality camera oh my god
he's here
oh hi Craig you're different
Tommy what god damn so ha yeah that's me
I'm gift for you a football you want
football catch it give it footballs in
your pocket when I say that that's
terrible yeah relax kriti it's okay you
look good anyway how is your sex relax
so much fun with him yeah Tommy see the
thing what thing the line motion I did
not hear it so shrew heesu bullshit I
did not hit her I did this is official
merchandise water baller remove EECOM
yeah no it's real fast real thing don't
talk too much
no this is always what he does for
school then he's not been he's cool then
he's not then he brings up the room and
everybody just forgets everything wait
that's not true is it Tommy okay quiet
look I have gift for your football look
yeah heck you to give us a minute or why
you chicken okay Tommy
you may have fooled your sheep no not
sheep it's chicken whatever you're not
fooling me one minute you're trying to
take down our videos the next you're
giving bizarrely kind interviews when
neither I or anyone else here is gonna
be manipulated by you any further oh did
you know nutballs Tommy was though is
here I just want to let you know in case
he
you know problems like this huh do
something crazy
I'll give for you okay here you go
Oh movie football yeah Wilson crossed
out and then just at the room so what
are you doing here you're walking accent
well I want to say fight is Oliver
critter I'm sorry okay everything he's
fine
yeah what's the angle not angle I want
to show people I can do more than just a
room you know I can I'm very versatile
actor no you can't Tommy you can only do
less far far less well I disagree with
your negative statement right there I
stop you right there you know with
proper studio Beeks our director camera
I can do anything I can do superhero I
could do dolphin I can do anything we
show you now we make new movies I'd like
to believe you Tommy actually no I
wouldn't but regardless you've gone back
and forth so much well believe nothing
ok I can show you
ha yeah we'll have ah there's the rub
as I think both you and I know nobody is
patient enough to put up with your
insanity anymore except him
[Music]
best friends is the first big outing
between cult stars graces taro and Tommy
Wiseau since they're now classic
disasterpiece the room Cisneros wrote
and produced this 2-part true story and
when I say true I mean you know how the
conjuring was technically true this is
the Annabel creation of that sister who
admitted that one of the reasons he
wanted to make this movie was to show
that his buddy was so can actually turn
in a legit performance okay I'll set the
legit bar to shack from Kazan and even
that I think is too high
anytime these two are together is
guaranteed to be weird but isn't an
entertaining kind of weird a passionate
kind of weird and most importantly a
different kind of weird than what we've
seen in the room well even if that's not
the case I think you get over well I
guess it only figures to give this movie
a fair shot let's take a look at best F
parentheses are and parentheses means oh
now I get it
the film starts off with an actually
beautiful looking shot wells grant that
conspiracy theory as we see sis Terra
waking up covered in blood not
remembering what happened so how most
actors wake up in LA he plays a man
named John who seems to be a Driftless
wanderer begging for money on the street
and I'm just gonna say it he is way too
good-looking to be your run-of-the-mill
beggar I mean there's living on the
street everyday and then there's Captain
America got a little dirty you can
practically see the cologne label under
him homeless man I've ever seen in my
life I can't bear tell you my
significant nothing right there talked
about someone else okay love obvious
homeless man has been catching my eye -
you want to play truth or dare
he comes across was so driving a hearse
and wearing platform shoes because we'd
be concerned if he didn't enter the
movie like that as he asked for help
carrying a coffin and the pee-wee
Herman's funeral parlour not still close
okay and they bite you oh I'm so sorry
about your father I cannot help you need
your karate but guess what you know what
I can't give you a job come on help me
with actually are you sure they didn't
accidentally cast this backwards
I could much easier see him waking up on
the street covered in blood
you will now meet my friend is still s
degree he took a bullet for his wife
he's safe his wife in answer to your
biggest question about how do you make
such an unbelievably strange man a
convincing character you just ride him
as an unbelievably strange character the
next one is very brutal we have to do
something special for him for funeral
okay he can be Marlon Brando or Tupac
Shakur now the comedy of the room came
from Tommy trying to convince us he's a
normal guy and spectacularly failing
here the comedy comes from how weird
Tommy is which is a very easy thing to
convey he plays an undertaker named
Harvey who has a passion for fixing dead
people's faces while he doesn't say it
well he does say it convincingly at
least in the strange environment the
film's established I have to change this
I had to give him beautiful faith Garry
grandeur James Dean that's what he needs
don't be scared ninja men I need your
help possibly the middle one even if I
never knew who Tommy was so was I'd say
this was good casting because his
delivery is just so strange but the
character is so strange
his foreign accent you know the American
one just adds another layer of mystery
to what this guy is about even though
he's clearly not good at communicating
you still buy that he's passionate about
communicating sustar plays the opposite
he barely talks throughout most of the
film anyone with sense would tell you
giving the majority of dialogue Ted this
guy would not be the wisest move but
cisneros quiet stares mixed with his own
mysterious background constantly has you
asking who are you supposed to be afraid
of
they're both odd in their own unique way
not knowing which one you're supposed to
be rooting for which one to be terrified
of perhaps maybe one of each or neither
and yes when there's a
to be funny if they are pretty funny I
gave you face of Jesus king of man in
the name of the Father Son and what they
ever I know tomorrow you be talking I
know that already
Harvey decides to give John some money
and doesn't even ask him about his
blood-stained shirt heck she just gives
him a new one take this one I always
have backup in case of blood is
surprisingly on me often whew it's a
Christmas movie actually don't give them
ideas John sees an ad about gold and
thinks back to the gold tooth that
Harvey pulled out after this interesting
encounter it's going up I sold mine well
now we know what happened to Emilio
estévez so after those words of wisdom
John gets a shave and a haircut and Troy
is using his voice again which he hasn't
utilized presumably since all the
dialogue he had in patch Adams can I
help you right can you help can you give
me a job and I'm just hopeless at this
at this time again I feel like this is
normal for how most actors practice
getting work in LA even down to being
under a bridge yeah because if anyone
would be afraid in this scenario it'd be
this guy afraid of this guy well in the
disaster artist it was a bryan cranston
thing but i never read that in the book
john asked for a job but harvey seems
less than enthusiastic no I can help you
I don't think so I can bring the trash
out I can you know what I give it advice
goes back to school yes if you goes back
to school you can speaks better English
Harvey decides to give him a chance is
he even the way he opens the door is
kind of a mystery
even the sterile has a look like that
was not in the script how did he do that
while cleaning John finds a bunch of
gold fillings harvey collected over the
years and steals them and just as harvey
made him a gift i made it can I have it
sure it's the most touching and
terrifying thing I've ever been given
thank you Harvey talks about how one of
his clients died and since he was
Chinese they should have Chinese food in
his honor good to know if Tommy died I
would have something from the planet
numbed war in his honor it was very kind
kind you know Chinese man Chinese use it
very self is it you know well that was
said hey what do you want well I'll give
credit I thought it'd be quicker than
the 25 minute mark before it finally
said what the hell was that
John gives the stolen fillings to a
dentist and makes a ton of money so he
returns to Harvey to pick up a
basketball to throw it back and forth
tonight yeah how are we gonna get there
you might be wondering what's wrong with
that movies do callbacks all the time so
what's wrong with this one the problem
is the movie is actually doing okay in
it's different tone that having a
callback while they're supposed to be
building character is taking us out of
the scene rather than sucking us in just
try to watch this scene and see if you
can focus on what they're actually
saying we have a girl or something
[Applause]
and just a heads up I didn't edit that
in look at the scene with just the audio
we have a girl or something still my own
thing
loneliness is hard sometimes but it's
easier than losing someone see you can
follow it fine now with the visual oh
[Applause]
hot critic did I mention I'm in the room
yes Tommy we all know you start in the
room Christ no I mentioned I in this
room right now why would you just
randomly say that because your memory
suspect I'm sorry to tell you you need
reminder you know my friend so tell me
what do you think about my performance
well it's actually pretty I'll get back
to you on it ah okay you take your time
I go to Holloway I leave in hard way
right now
oh hi Holloway okay I mean hard way
I'm so uncomfortable he knows where I
work harvey decides to go to vegas then
now you didn't take john with him I have
to admit I didn't think you could get a
stranger duo in a convertible near Vegas
than these two but with these guys
anything is possible
ever credible they have some fun in the
city and find a quiet spot to look at
the Stars and chill I love The Book Of
Mice and Men have you read that book
they had a happy ending right I always
saw myself and Leni and George you know
these two people just wanting to live
off the fat of the land and have a place
to call home
yeah the parallels are so thick tell me
about the chickens George GTG hey don't
worry listen don't worry about she's out
there look in the sky hello
what I like is even what was so
interrupts an emotional line that
clearly wasn't planned it still kind of
fits because the character is so odd and
it keeps the scenes lively or she died
she died when the observatory when this
next scene I honestly don't have words
for it just watch you look at the x-ray
look at he's swole candle and the second
candle put in his ass what about that
what yeah right this entire if I was so
weird Wow yeah they're weird I he'll I
don't think there's anything I can say
that can make this funny or sensical so
we'll just let it exist in the universe
John explains to Harvey that he stole
the fillings but he wants to bring him
in on it to sell the rest of them and
you know how I said Tommy's weirdness
usually works in his favor with this
role there's a reason I use the word
usually John you steal from me you still
for my friend you sell body part on the
black market why are you doing this why
yeah sometimes it sounds like he just
woke up and if he finishes a scene he
can go back to napping surprisingly
there is a difference between that and
the rest of his acting how much I don't
know until he comes here and looks at it
she dazed on my day you better pray
something really weird is said to
distract us when you end up in jail
I will not rescue you okay the only see
what I can do I can send you a few
oranges that should do it he agrees to
meet up with someone who will give cash
for the fillings and things get pretty
funny again because we see Harvey
interact with someone other than John
this just makes the interactions all the
more humorous when you see the reaction
to was so obviously improvising and
getting some of the lines wrong yeah you
told me are you lying to me man some
places do that huh it's very starting to
rebel
problem again he's clearly flopping
stuff but it kinda works for both the
character and us knowing the actors are
trying their best to work with it kind
of how the characters would probably try
their best to work with it you try to
come here to test me I bet you fucker
you want I am all anything nothing we're
on again it's a different kind of
awkward than the room because no improv
was used there here it seems more
welcomed and it still stays true to the
scene and characters hell I can see his
character or Tommy frisking people when
they enter his home that and you know
some of these lines were therapeutic for
these actors who the fuck is this Goblin
yeah was so that'll teach you to show up
23 hours late that's almost a day he
seems legit uncomfortable which I think
ties into how more relaxed he is with
John making their friendship all the
more interesting he doesn't really see
too many other people they discover
though he has a lot of feelings so they
give him a ton of money his down payment
for it all harvey hides the money in an
ATM machine he keeps in his garage again
diehard wondering if the real was so has
that john of his new girlfriend named
tracy sit down and watch edwin movies
you know I never thought I would enjoy
watching these Black Knight movie so
much but it's as if the last 10 minutes
they're all about trusting no one if
that's what you got out of Glen or
Glenda I have far more questions for you
that you probably have answers he
finally tells her about selling the
fillings but she doesn't like being lied
to so he takes her to meet up with
Harvey that'll put her mind at ease haha
you know what some days he was supposed
to oh yeah I don't need him to support
me variant
oh the same might be shot from a
distance but the awkward is a pure
closeup what's your story what is your
story actually where are you from fun an
earth okay that suspension of disbelief
I just can't buy Harvey think she's a
gold digger so he refuses to give John
any of the money they made and on top of
that he's apparently putting down a lot
of money on something with the actors
from the league but lies to John about
it saying the guy is just applying to be
a janitor not trusting him anymore John
hatches up a plan with Tracy to make him
think he's going to a Rolling Stones
concert while she steals the ATM we got
you tickets to the Rolling Stones
oh that's my favorite that's your
favorite band I figured be Alvin and the
Chipmunks or something
but Harvey figures out the tickets are
fake and he asked John to pull over I
gotta tell you something dad
why bother again this is one of the
scenes where Tommy's acting doesn't work
and to his credit there's amazingly few
of them in this movie and arguably this
is the last one but it is also the
funniest one I give you everything job
friendship advice if they give me
nothing
that reaction was so silly it actually
sonicboom to the movie like the film
became conscious and had to laugh at how
goofy it was but Harvey falls off a
cliff and John is talk not knowing what
to do thus ending part 1 hmm hey Tommy
oh hi critic damn it get the real Tommy
in here
oh ok ah anyways how is your sex life
come on no seriously critic how is your
sex life nevermind Tommy I have to ask
how do these movies keep going if you
one of the biggest draws is suddenly
gone ah you must be far too now ha you
didn't expect got ready for crazy time
he's about to get very weird after Tommy
leaves the films is where it gets weird
[Applause]
[Music]
so while I certainly didn't expect
anything normal from an outing with Greg
Sestero and Tommy Wiseau I don't wonder
how things can possibly get stranger
with less with so in it well it starts
off relatively normal relatively being a
relative term as John and Tracey find
the ATM and are unable to open it so
they toss it in their car but the film
quickly ups the question marks as it
cuts forward to John being handcuffed on
the stairs and I have a good story for
you a familiar story was so a lot
lingers beside him hey hey I was
promised dead was so maybe there wasn't
a lead up with a light as a feather TV
but I was still promised it seems to cut
back and for showing how John got to
everybody's worst nightmare of being
handcuffed by Tommy as we cut back to
how it all happened Tracey and John hit
the road trying to figure out how
they're gonna open the safe with all the
money inside but of course they're
pulled over tags are expired
what really I'll get it fixed first
thing in the morning I was just thinking
we can take care of it right here in
Brainerd the cop like in most
traditional thrillers is a freaking
dumbass and doesn't search the Congress
allowing them to stop at a nearby hotel
with an extremely odd person Manning it
this is an exclusive residence it's a
private retreat just one a few hours
hold on a minute
let me check something I'll be right
back Norman Bates wishes he could be
this off-putting
just make sure you sign the guestbook
before you leave bitches what bitches I
swear you could hear a mic drop after he
said that line bitches I've only just
met this weirdo and I already know
everything about him who he is how many
people he killed in the hilarious ways
he killed them
what's leanest damn it I made a phone
call someone's on their way to get us
but we continue with the story that were
given as Tracy makes a call to her uncle
Rick who says he's gonna come and help
them out Uncle Rick it's kind of where
things get amazing like it will work out
in Midnight punk
look out of your eye John not for you
the actor playing him is named Rick
Edwards and the best way I can describe
him is bizarro Tommy was so the
character was created specifically to
mirror several elements of Briggs life
so it shot at his actual home in the
mountains which is decorated all the
achievements of when he was an athletic
rower in the movie they also make him a
football star he does midnight pull-ups
just because he starred in a soap opera
as well as an Italian fantasy called
hearts and armor while also modeling
acting sports and modeling this is the
Dos Equis guy if he was a cowboy
I once wrestles the Gator down in the
manchow swamp and I kicked his ass or
tail or whatever you want to call him
the reason I called bizarro Tommy was so
though as well Tommy will try new things
usually won't work and act overly weird
Rick will try new things haven't go
tremendously well and act just the right
amount of weird but still clearly weird
I hung in there manned up I took her
down we had a great time that was fun I
got to tell you there was why you gotta
just go for that kind of stuff yeah and
yes he takes up a lot of the movie hey
there's food in the fridge I'm not gonna
fuckin babysitter
come on guys make yourselves at home I'm
gonna sit back get drunk
well drunker it's almost as if he
hijacks the film you're not supposed to
like him cuz he's the villain of the
movie but he just dominates every scene
he's in we just listen to a make bad
jokes weird small talk and laugh at the
most random moments and I got a cougar
stalking me she lives next door I don't
know what chuck norris memes are still a
thing but they need to be replaced with
Rick Edwards memes I was your terrible
idea to come here
and you tell me your uncle is Clint
Eastwood makes me embarrassed I've been
doing my Owen Wilson voice this whole
time Jones tries to feel bad about
Harvey's death but what's the point when
you're staying in the house of the only
guy who could possibly upstage him just
look at his nightly regiment I feel like
he's gonna turn to a wear linebacker
even when trippy dreams of Tommy tries
to steal the spotlight back it's no good
this guy it's just so enjoyably kooky
it's like they're having a weird off
seriously critic you find somebody we're
than me
I'm not weirder but just a cool kind of
weird so what's this me this person is
big R star weird than me I'm not
weirdest in your eyes Tommy in all my
life I've never seen anyone weirder than
you oh wow what is compliment you know
you always have nice things to say at
the end of dare your little tricky
you put deer on my ass but I'd end up
day you're a nice guy after all I don't
know everything today should concern me
right can't seem to get the ATM safe
open but that doesn't mean they can't
look up other options good computer I
can use guest passcode is fu 1986 after
you yeah fuck you okay are you they find
a guy in Tombstone who is apparently
good at cracking safes so they send a
guy to the place and hey I didn't know
they could afford dr. Demento hey look
it's my ex-wife she had all the money I
mean nobody likes a box they can't open
any more than I do all right
you're like you've guessed Don didn't
die and he lived into retirement first
things first I'm gonna have to have a
whiskey over ice got no wine for my walk
I opened this thing for you but after I
finished my drink you know are they
making up for Tommy not being in this by
making everyone else
curiously odd no this is clearly a
three-person job so let's all pour it
together Vinnie we got ourselves a
golden goose so the safecracker give us
a call to a shady friend before
attempting to rob them himself get over
here
give the wall come on oh please don't
kill us I can't leave such an
embarrassing obituary
okay a young guy with tattoos five
o'clock shadow wife-beater shirt I can
kind of see how that will come across as
pretty intimidating but teamed up with a
badly traced picture of John Williams
surprisingly sucks out the fear factor
quite a bit they're gonna have to really
up the creep value if they want to keep
us intimidated remember when Tommy was
improvising earlier that was pretty
silly Oh God well this is definitely not
the room room maybe but not the room but
somebody breaks in and saves her while
also taking out the mad magazine parody
of Nick Nolte here hey I'll make the
jokes around here Oh Who am I kidding
you can make up any jokes you want you
freaking weirdo so we're in the last
third of Part two and little action has
happened we're in a totally different
place one of the main characters
arguably the selling point only makes an
appearance once in a while and I weirdly
love it because of that it is slow but
it's just so puzzling in its attitude
that it's really fun not knowing if
something is going to be intensely
aggressive intensely silly or both as
long as this guy is rambling about
something uncomfortable I see it as a
win keep your heads down guys Traci not
that far down
who are you you're like that perverted
uncle everybody laughs wit but they
still keep their distance from Rick has
that early morning drink of Champions
while John discovers Harvey's car is in
Rick's garage John demand some answers
and unfortunately he gets them I've
never had this much trouble than anybody
else
finish packing baby
[Music]
that doesn't mean they're a thing they
said they scan people they lie all the
time maybe they're lying about being
related I know what you're thinking did
I fuck her five or six times you might
be related fucking her so hard last
night I thought there was gonna be a
headboard homicide I'm supposed to hate
you but I want to hate you the same way
I hate the people from Game of Thrones
not the people from Game of Thrones
thankfully they clarified they're not
related and this was all part of a scam
oh yeah I can go back to laughing at
stuff like this again you look like a
school girl that's just seeing her first
pecker who are you it looks like John is
in a tight spot though but thankfully he
has a back-up plan
fuck's sake there Karate Kid
I didn't say it was a good one but
someone opens fire on them and this guy
is so badass he actually orders dinner
while in the middle of a shootout I'll
do the steak fajitas Thanks
so yeah just remember if you're an
impotent man just take two helpings of
watching this guy you'll be instantly
cured Jon literally runs for the hills
Rick chases after him the shooter chases
after Rick and this builds up to the
bizarre ending of no critic you give
everything away but I usually talk about
the endings in my review it's a full
analysis no but you need to keep
surprised audience will surprise well
are you gonna kill all the way up here
talk to you you know I give away Andy
you know what fine I think these movies
are good enough that they deserve to
have some of the surprises unspoiled all
I'm gonna say is and I know I'm going
out on a limb it gets a little odd so
you mean you like movie and what about
my performance you know Tommy in the
strange way it's done yeah I actually
think you'd do a good job I've ly Oscar
it's not that good
I've ly Oscar I think the cutoff date
was already a long time Oscar you might
win an Oscar Tommy ah
I know I know I mean Oscar
so yeah I legitimately enjoy both of
these films I'll get for a warning
though that they're not just another
version of the room and they might not
be for everyone if you saw the room you
might appreciate parts of it more like
Tommy's line delivery and an occasional
in-joke but it is a lot more slower
artsy that was just saying confident
there are still plenty of moments there
laughably strange but I think they're
intentionally that way it had kind of an
otherworldly feel to it that almost
makes you feel like you're in another
dimension but one where the focus can
suddenly change out of nowhere leaving
you scratching your head as to what can
happen next it's kind of hard to say
whether or not a classify it as a comedy
it certainly has funny pars but it also
has moments of heavy atmosphere and
intensity that are legitimately affected
I can't say this is a movie for a wide
audience but that's part of what I like
about it did what it wanted in its own
way for its own reasons and gave us
something pretty unique and I can see a
definitely growing of following for how
oddly passionate for how passionately
odd it is both films are a strange
experience you won't be forgetting it
anytime soon and Tommy I know you'll
always be connected to the room mostly
by your own doing but I can say that you
gave a performance in the film that
legitimately worked for the reasons they
were supposed to work well I thank you
agree I appreciate you mean means a lot
you know means a lot
hey Tommy let's go I'll be there two
minutes mark no no don't say that other
line oh my god
mr. James Franco's brother look guys
you're great and all but we really got
to go if you want someone to talk to you
call this guy all right we'll see you
next time Tommy let's go what a story
it's still Greg
what do you give you Skype number of
somebody
hey there critic my hair who is he he's
like the best part from the movie best
friends glad to see you're such a fan I
don't care about him
yeah we only like the room guys oh no no
this is like the most amazing person
ever he just don't know it yet
well I bet he doesn't do anything with
footballs he is literally a football
star in the movie doesn't count
I missed that floor in homeless man come
on maybe we could shot some more quotes
in as they leave I'm sorry man they just
don't know your awesomeness yet oh it's
okay everybody who denies me will be
left behind in the rapture yeah what the
rapture of those who don't believe that
I'm the coolest human being alive
thankfully you realized it in time it
should take place any minute what was it
always playing that way no I I just
decided it right now
thank God I regret words man holy shit
a unicorn made of chain saws is gonna
drop by and send you to paradise I'm
gonna go juggle some sharks for a while
listen thanks for being such a fan it
means a lot thank you
I'm the Nostalgia Critic be sure to
watch best friends with Rick Edwards it
could save your life
the only see what I can do I can send
you few oranges
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out the International Rescue
Committee is this week's charity this
organization responds to the world's
worst humanitarian crisis and helps
people whose lives and livelihoods are
shattered by conflict and disaster to
survive recover and gain control of
their future the IRC has grown because
their teams have gone through the
toughest places done cutting-edge
research developed in-depth knowledge
and forged vital relationships with
local governments today their 191 field
offices in over 30 crises torn countries
are helping communities survive conflict
and recover from war and natural
disaster if you look at their site in
their YouTube channel you can see so
many people around the world going
through such hardship but you can play a
big part in helping them return to the
life they deserve click on the link and
show your support for the men women and
children who deserve to be rescued
[Music]
you